austin i will see you all this weekend
september 2nd and 3rd get your tickets
to those shows at ryansickler.com
vancouver i'll be up there september
15th through the 17th in edmonton i'll
be there at the end of the month
september 29th through october 1st get
your tickets to those shows and all
shows on my website at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media and i want to say thank you
thank you
for your support thank you for watching
the show listen if you are watching
please hit the subscribe button on
youtube it's a free way to help the show
you're already there watching it anyway
i can see how you're doing it thank you
very much hit that subscribe help the
show out set your little reminder and
boom it comes up in your feed it's that
easy all right if you gotta have more
honey dude then you gotta check out the
patreon it's called the honeydew with
the all where i highlight the lowlights
with y'all
and nobody can touch your stories all
right it's the craziest [ __ ] you've ever
heard i promise your word well over 200
episodes i know 100 episodes in now and
um it's five bucks a month that's it if
you sign up for a year you get over a
month free and you're getting the
honeydew a day early ad free at no
additional cost all right if you or
someone you know
has that story that has to be heard
please submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com all right now
tour dates august going to be in la
jolla august 5th through the 7th i'm
going to be in philadelphia august 18th
through the 20th and i will be in austin
actually labor day weekend september 2nd
and third get your tickets to the night
panthnation tour on my website at
ryanstickler.com now you guys know what
we do over here i always say we're
highlighting the low lights and these
are the stories behind the storytellers
today i'm very excited to have this
guest on first time here on the honeydew
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
steph tolab welcome to the honeybee yeah
thank you big applause thank you for
being here
thanks for having me you're welcome um
before we get into everything please
plug it all right now do it
i will be in toronto august 25th okay no
wait i'll be
i don't know i will be in toronto
opening up for bill burr yeah at the
scotiabank arena it's the biggest arena
i've ever done my life i feel crazy
august 23rd 24th and then august 25th
i'll be doing a doubleheader in toronto
um so if you're in toronto come to those
and then uh i
can't remember the other ones i think
just add me on instagram snapchat love
and then you'll see my tour dates and
that's that's that it's all there yeah
all right and your podcast in my podcast
i have two podcasts i have one that i do
on my own called steph infection and
it's all about gross body ailments so if
you go you gotta do it i'm sure you got
some weird [ __ ] body [ __ ] not to
think about it i've been i've been lucky
you son of a [ __ ]
it's people who had like horrible
ailments and weird fluke acts and stuff
like that and then another podcast with
jessica michelle singleton and laura
bites called slobs and you can both of
them are
very different so listen to both if you
like podcasts i mean
same you know like and listen you know
well also you have a special out on uh
epics you had an hour special which is
where i first met you i'm probably
didn't meet you there but it's where i
really got to know you because i got to
sit and interview you for yeah it was
going to be a very similar it's going to
be a very it's going to be a very
similar um but a lot of that be cut out
of the interview so we can really dive
into it um
yeah i did half hour don't get carried
you did i thought you did an hour no i
was 30. oh was it oh that's right the
second season was hours sorry
half an hour um and yeah i just did that
uh bilbo represents friends who yup kale
on netflix so you can see me on there
yeah you're doing great right now yeah
it's good it's going well
um so let's go back to a time when it
wasn't so great can we do that first of
all where are you from originally you're
toronto toronto ontario okay yes so
you're canadian
and you're now here living full-time and
have been full-time when did you get to
the states seven years ago okay so i was
in toronto the whole time i started
coming when i was 18 years old and i've
been doing
it the whole time a long time um that's
when people like this netflix came up
some people commenting wow she's new i'm
like
nah [ __ ] i'm i'm old as hell i'm
botox is helping i'm old as [ __ ] um
but yeah i started in toronto and then
uh moving out here is a nightmare
and then getting that you came here
for comedy okay yeah um so go back to
toronto what's it like what was growing
up do you have sisters brothers what was
your family like i have um
my family was very insane i'm bulgarian
i know if you know not a lot of people
know about bulgarians uh very angry
people so my dad's bulgarian my mom's
like a regular canadian gal and my mom
and i have one sister and my mom is a
highland dancing teacher and started
doing that when she was 20 years old so
those who don't know how they're dancing
it's like scott like scotland like
bagpipes kilts you know the whole
[ __ ]
toss yes yes that's one okay okay it is
uh so my mom
was a teacher so i was forced into it
when i was three years old so like i'm
three three years old
and there's videos of it if no one
believes me i have [ __ ] video footage
of me three years [ __ ] old i used to
like my mom was so obsessed with me
becoming like a champion when i was in
like fifth grade i used to have to come
home at recess and practice because i
was like really good when i was nine
years old she wanted to be like the
tiger woman
oh yeah and because she's the teacher
she wanted her daughter to be like yeah
you can't be a failure i was [ __ ]
i was dog [ __ ] i had like huge feet i
had my dad's back i'm like why am i
[ __ ] no nightmare i was not a dancer
look at my body this is not a dancer's
body like it was a nightmare
but it was like my whole life i've never
heard that oh my god damn life if you
don't say that [ __ ] on stage you better
i got my dad's back i have my dad's
whole [ __ ] body it's like
yeah so it was like my whole life was
literally dancing like hitting it three
but driving it like that yeah
if you got 15 minutes your ass better be
dancing yep so every i would practice my
mom taught you sisters both of us so we
go right from school i'd wait for her
after school i'd walk her up to the
dance studio it was in the church so
we'd go there four nights a week every
weekend there was a competition so every
weekend at [ __ ] 6 a.m i'm getting up
[ __ ] getting ready
this is my life this is my sports this
is my and it's like you know it's fun if
it is and also my parents would run the
competitions so i'd have to help like as
a kid i had to help do like the like
lining up the kids and doing like the
[ __ ] registration and [ __ ] like it
was a nightmare so when i got like high
school i was like i can't do this
anymore i'm not drinking my friends so
like 2 a.m and now i'm like you did this
all the way in the house all the way to
18 years old 18 18 no yes you're a
junior in high school out there doing
this [ __ ] yeah no i did this for a long
[ __ ] time and i was bad for a lot of
it i was only good when i was nine so
picture peaking at nine and then being
dragged out for [ __ ] years
dragged like it was a nightmare and we
traveled we thought the only thing was
that was good was that we traveled a lot
so
every year we go to scotland and like
compete out there because it's like a
big world championship
they're not doing well in the states i
gotta imagine you're probably no offense
you're getting your ass handed to you in
scotland oh i wouldn't even place
i wouldn't even place i was dog [ __ ] in
the motherland oh i was literally dog
[ __ ] and like danced your ass right off
that stage oh no i was like
the worst thing was too my mom has a
student who's like i think to this day
still holds the guinness book records
for the most consecutive world
championships one in a row so this is in
scotland there's like a big world series
every year so she
i think she won 11 years straight and
then there's me big footed clawed hopper
[ __ ] clown shoes up there like i was
i was me and my sister both
i'm not saying we're big girls but we're
not tiny girls so we were like
clowning around up there like we both
were good when we were kids and then we
should have stopped we should have
stopped as soon as we got to high school
you're hard into it it's hard to be up
there doing some [ __ ] like that when you
don't want to no we were we were really
really [ __ ] and then when did you get
the courage to finally tell your mom
like look i'm [ __ ] enough of this
[ __ ] i think you became a legal adult
yeah when i could legally like [ __ ]
vote in canada um
literally it was bad wow that's good no
it was we had no way out and because we
had to help the competitions it was so
[ __ ] bad
how did she
well see that this is the problem she's
not good so she wanted me
to sorry
both of you were like [ __ ] it or just
both of us were bad both of us like
drugs and alcohol in high school so we
didn't want to do any more and we both
really got into sports so me and my
sister both played lacrosse in high
school we're both in the track team
um we were like super into sports and my
dad would like train us to run cause my
dad used to be a cross-country runner so
he'd help us train to runs like we were
better at sports we should have done
that but we [ __ ] didn't
uh it was bad it was bad but then my mom
wanted me to take over the dancing
school so i taught for her a little bit
in high school so i had like four or
five students that i would teach to come
my parents house they like the basement
was like read down with the mirrors and
like a little stage and stuff
did i want to do that no i hate it out
of the house this is happening yeah so i
would teach her the students my mom
didn't want to out of your house the
younger ones well she taught in the
studio and i got the little
idiots that wouldn't listen
uh and i wasn't i had no point did i
ever have papers to teach i was not
qualified to do this and then for a year
i played uh the bagpipes because you did
not i did because my mom wanted me to
play them at the competitions because
there's a live bag playing the bagpipes
right now you really could no so you
start on a chanter
so in like high school
i started becoming
obsessed thinking every man was a
pervert i got followed once when i was
like me and my two friends in like great
eight we got followed by this creepy guy
who like in a car how tall walking we
were walking down i remember my first
encounter the performer i was always
like that kid that was like huh that
guy's weird something i i my peripheral
vision is crazy and i can like i
remember every [ __ ] little detail of
everything so we're walking down this
like it's my home depot so it's like
factories my friends was weird into the
street so we're walking it was a great
day i think it's great seven
three of us were walking and i'm like
this guy's weird he's wearing a suit i'm
like who the [ __ ] wears a suit in the
middle of the summer and by home depot
like this guy's not normal so i'm like i
think he's following stuff stop being
superior i'm like no we're getting
[ __ ] followed so we start walking a
bit faster and then he's like catching
up and i'm like oh we're getting [ __ ]
followed so he start running he has
running after us what is this one man
gonna do for three also he was like half
my size like this small man is gonna
what the [ __ ] is gonna happen so we run
her [ __ ] front doors close we run her
back doors not available
i don't know like because you can't be
that much of a pervert like what were
you going to do
creepy so ever since that i was like
every little piece of anything so
everyone's perfect to me
it's it's doing this show and it's only
been a few years
i'm 49 now so i'd say in the last two
years it's taken a woman to sit across
from me and say something like
every man that walks by me i fear
every one of these people could take me
and i was like
man
never
rarely
have i ever worried about another dude
doing that but i'll never have i worried
about a woman passing me anything you
know what i mean like what a world to
have to live in to be oh don't stop
luckily and then they have that kind of
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
but luckily i was in canada so it wasn't
like as scary i'd walk home a lot at
night but like so the reason i fired my
piping teacher so it was a chance you
learned on a chapter god
i was like you had to play and you'd
have to play and i'd hold it here so
it'd be raped with my boob so i was like
you know you're growing up your boobs
are like i don't know when you're
younger you know you don't have booze
like you get a weird growth spurt where
they're like little triangles and you're
super self-conscious anyways i kept
thinking it was looking my tit so i'd
wear like three sweaters so i'd be in
the middle of summer and i'm like trying
to play this [ __ ] thing out of this
dripping sweat
so finally my mom and dad splurge they
buy this like used bagpipes like so
because if you learn on this first and
you attach it whatever
so i get the bagpipes and the teacher's
name won't say his name
but you know you are if you're listening
he takes the bagpipes and he goes oh you
gotta wet the reed and i'm like oh dude
he goes no i'll do it this man
starts sucking my bagpipes like deep
throwing them no like like like go and
i'm like oh i remember being like oh my
god no and i was like so i'm like i
think i was like 16 the time i'm like
this obese man just sucking my [ __ ]
for way too long way too long and i was
like at all it was way too long
i don't think that's how you wet it he
goes your turn i'm like no your turn i
go i don't feel well i feel sick so he
leaves my dad comes downstairs this
isn't me sitting on the couch like what
i'm like i quit i'm with me you get
[ __ ] quick he's my beard he just
sucked the pipes like a kid my dad was
like yeah and i was like okay fine you
don't play anywhere else
my dad's like no no you you did he go
say something to the guy no no because
he was like part of the my mom's dancing
school and they were already weird no no
it was just like swept under the rock
see like nowadays you'd say something
probably [ __ ] yeah but back then people
were back then i'm actually like i'm
whatever i was like
you don't say things like this
no it was still like yeah it was still
kind of frowning like yeah yeah if you
talk about what he just did what i would
go right up after that oh
literally this is what you said this is
a where was this at your house in my
house
did that what the walls of this man in
your home with your dad oh my dad was
upstairs with his headphones on
listening to old like that's how [ __ ]
people get killed that is how people get
killed no this man wasn't well
and i'm like i'll never play again every
time i like look the big pipes i just
pictured the it was like
oh i'm getting sick i'm getting sick
reliving the memory
bad memory um
what so that was that in high school was
yeah so that was like
part of my high school nightmare um i
know we talked before we were recording
outside and we talked about you were
bullied bad when when did the bullying
begin great so grade
8 the year i came out of my shell so i
was like kind of like i spent most of my
time with hanging out with dancing
people i didn't have a lot of school
friends because i was like i didn't know
after school program i'd be dancing on
weekends i didn't hang out with them i'd
be with my dancing friends so i never
had any school friends so finally in
grade eight you had classmates yeah i
had like one good friend in middle
school and that was it like i had like
uh yes one girl irish shadow diver she's
great um
so i came to my shell in grade eight and
then eighth grade for you americans uh
and i got i was weird i like knew i was
weird i like looked weird i had like a
big nose and a small head like i didn't
grow into my nose yet i was like tomboy
like i had full unibrow like i was i
looked like a boy okay boy in grade six
like just photos of me i could give you
them for the podcast like if you saw a
photo you'd be like that's a boy like it
was my hair was like i would wear full
adidas track suits full unibrow just
nose it was a nose and hair like there's
a nose and adidas that's all it was as a
nose and two eyes um in a track sleeve
it attracts you so i knew it was ugly
and
all the boys told me that so in grade
eight ingredients started with this guy
daniel
i hope you're listening i don't give a
[ __ ] even though my manager specifically
told me to stop saying people's names um
leave out the last name there daniel
bleep um
daniel bleep uh i remember grade eight
was like break your [ __ ] nose so you
get that thing fixed disgusting and then
there's a member of the girl antoinette
she liked to chime in too so i had like
two or three bullies in grade eight that
would constantly call me ugly and big
nose whatever i'm like okay maybe
they'll end in high school so i get to
high school and it's three thousand
times worse so in grade nine kicked into
higher gear that got so bad so i was
best friends with the two hottest girls
in my grade they were all the guys
wanted them and there's me this nose
hanging out with them and i was like
very outgoing and the guys didn't like
it because they would like i guess give
me attention all the [ __ ] guys
so
there was this group of greek guys that
[ __ ] hated me i don't know what the
[ __ ] happened they accused me of like
being in the way of their relationships
i'm like my friends were never gonna
[ __ ] you like first of all no one's
[ __ ] one great night you sick pigs
maybe some people are i don't know i
lost virginia late anyways long story
short day like in grade the end of the
year
was a yearbook signing this is the most
vivid memory i have of it they took my
yearbook into the boys bathroom and they
defaced every page saying i'm ugly i'm
never gonna be alone are you serious
yeah they like literally uh made a name
for me they still have the yearbook
called igra i think i'm at ugly and
greek and they would write it on every
single page i remember crying so i'm
like give me your book back there's this
guy i liked a lot kevin kevin clayton if
you're out there still um and i like i
had a huge crush on him and they knew it
so they took his page and they scribbled
on his face and they wrote he'll never
like you you're [ __ ] ugly all this
[ __ ] and then my friend like my other
good friend ashley in high school who
took her yearbook and cut out kevin from
hers and taped it onto mine sweetest
signature no i always get upset think of
that um yeah that same day one of the
guys nico i'm gonna say his full name
i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] we are
outside uh
all signing your books and he came up to
me goes take off your halloween mask you
ugly [ __ ] so i slapped him across the
face
he slapped me back no he slapped me back
and all the greek boys pointed and
laughed oh yeah i'll never it's like
cemented in my [ __ ] head how could it
not it was so yeah i was like tormented
they all every i walked in the hall like
the worst thing was i remember i'd walk
down the hall alone the big [ __ ] big
nose you [ __ ] flat-chested [ __ ] i'd
be like who are you doing this for no no
one else is around like bullying me
around other people makes sense but
they'd bully me like one-on-one i might
get so [ __ ] hurtful but by the end of
high school
i started doing all the plays and i
started like
yeah i like you know i was in every play
i was like the start of every play i was
like you know the funniest ever was i
was the highlight of all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] we did i got on uh student council
i was like the social uh functions
person and then two of them apologized
yeah why two of them one of them i
remember gus uh i'm just saying
everyone's name
it's like awful i remember all this but
i wish i didn't what did he say and how
how did it go in grade 12 i had a party
and he showed up like what the [ __ ] are
you doing here he goes i honestly just
came he's like i know you don't want me
here he's like i am so sorry he's like
we are just being childish it was it was
i i think we were just we didn't know
how to handle how outgoing stuff you
were but like you you didn't deserve
that and i just want to deeply apologize
and i was like and i forgave him because
i was like okay that's a bigger man and
another guy mike that i saw a year after
high school in um at a bar he was
hammered and he used to every day call
me [ __ ] dante's peak toucan sam like
every [ __ ] day i was like god damn it
he um he's at a bar and he's hammered
and he's like punch me and he's like oh
my god he's like [ __ ] punch me i was
such an [ __ ] do you [ __ ] do and it
took every ounce of my soul not to i
just went
no i'm like you don't [ __ ] deserve it
i don't get the [ __ ] on my face that was
it i never done now i just have crazy
resentment towards people still but i
was like it was bad man i kind of like
it faded out a little bit in grade 10
but not as much like they were still
like rude as hell did you ever get in
the outside of uh slapping the one guy
did you ever get in any other fights
over it
no was it just boys were the girls
involved as well boys just guys
i mean i did get in a fight with a girl
in grade 10 i got arrested for assault
tell me that why that was a side note um
sidenote ended up with a record what did
you do yeah um
i was dating this yugoslavian guy
and uh long story short i think there
was like another he was having girl who
maybe liked him or was jealous that i
was dating she was 11 guy
so we were in gym class i remember she
was like screwing up the games and i
kept losing when i was on our team so i
got pissed so we a lot of cut ice anyway
so one day i'm in the math hallway
another very vivid memory
and it's her and these two girls and i
walk by and i'm like
what's your [ __ ] problem it's the
[ __ ] cut eye [ __ ] and whatever being
like saucy and then she comes back at me
saying some [ __ ] and then her friend
that i've never seen in my life shoves
me and i'm like
the [ __ ] so i shove her back and then my
friend who i won't name because she
hates when i [ __ ] tell the story she
comes out of nowhere she's like what the
[ __ ] shoves this girl off of me she rips
the wanker whips off my friend's gold
necklace my friend's like well i'm just
going down beat down um
so i look over and my friend is just
like punching her like they're they're
all in gym class no this is all in the
math hallway but it's all over
from gym class oh this is in school
teacher runs out we're like ah we all
leave the [ __ ] building
we go across to this pizza place and i'm
like we're just like you know we're
jacked out we just got in this [ __ ]
fight we're like what the [ __ ]
my friend's like i'm going home i'm like
i'm going to fifth period i'm like i
don't do [ __ ] i'm not getting in trouble
so i go to fifth period i remember
asking i was my presentation and
speaking teacher mr black and i'm like
hey there's cameras in the school right
and he's like yeah and i go okay he's
like why i go they record right he's
like yes stephanie why are you asking
something it doesn't matter because in
my head i'm like if they see the cameras
they'll see that she initiated the fight
and then we were standing up for
ourselves that and i knew i'm like
whatever i'm like probably suspended
whatever so i come to school the next
day everyone's talking about i feel
pretty cool i'm like i think it's very
loving actually i'm like oh yeah yeah we
felt pretty hot shots over here once you
happen about it so i'm in now in math
class fifth period
knock on the door opens it up it's like
one of the i don't know something like
teacher guy who just helps out
and he's like can stephanie please come
out and tell her to get all of her stuff
and everyone's like oh and i'm like
you did that so cocky i would see you in
two days [ __ ] so i'm walking
down the hallway and he's like you are
in more trouble than you know and i'm
like i don't do [ __ ] he goes
when we get to the office don't talk and
i'm like okay so i get the office i'm
sitting there also i should i should
clarify we had uniforms so i'm wearing a
little schoolgirl kilt
i was a punker so i had like a dog
collar on i had pink streaks in my hair
i had all these like homemade socks like
i was like i thought it was so [ __ ]
cool
i'm sitting there i haven't remember i
had this big roxy backpack with bling 22
patches all over it this woman comes
over to me she was just your back yeah
she opens it i go hello oh my bag she
goes you the right for me and silent
anything you say will i'm like
excuse me she goes
you have the right to remain silent i'm
like who the [ __ ] are you what is going
on right now you're getting arrested for
putting a girl in the hospital and i was
like
i look over my friend is like she sees
my face i immediately start crying i'm
like
losing my mind we get handcuffed in the
school office i have to clear out the
school oh yeah what do you mean clear
out the story so they like everyone have
to get out so they walked up see you oh
yeah they walked us down the [ __ ]
thing also didn't ask us a single thing
i'm like look at the cameras i kept
yelling look at the cameras we get taken
out i'm in a cop car in front of the
school everyone's looking in i'm sobbing
my eyes i remember i was crying so bad
they did this in front of all the
students oh yeah and the teachers
everybody it was a [ __ ] parade and
then i'm like
crying so bad the cop was like this
young hot [ __ ] cop oh god he was hot
i'm like i didn't do anything i swear
and he was like shoving mcdonald's
napkins through the [ __ ] bars and
he's like i'm just the driver and i was
just like
sobbing on the way to the police station
my mom's dancers two of the dancers
pulled up beside me and they see me and
i go i didn't
my mom's gonna [ __ ] kill me
so the funniest part of this whole thing
so we get taken to um the local precinct
by our house whatever we both get put in
these two separate rooms they weren't
like a cell but it was like an all metal
room whatever my friend is laughing she
finds this hilarious because she's like
we didn't do it like what the [ __ ] do we
do and i'm like i'm dead i'm murdered so
the
the principal wasn't there that day when
this all happened so the vice principal
calls my dad and my dad has a bunch of
prankster buddies so the principal calls
my dad and goes hello um mr tolav this
is so and so from a short collegiate uh
your daughter's uh been arrested for
assault so my dad goes [ __ ] you steve
and then hangs up the phone
calls back um actually no this is the
vice principal and my dad's like oh [ __ ]
like thought it was a prank call
and then yeah turns out we got um
initially we got expelled so my dad we
got expelled and arrested so uh full
fingerprints the whole deal so we uh my
dad goes back in to like be like what's
going on my daughter didn't get her say
the story you just literally so what
happened was a girl came in the next
morning with her mom opened the yearbook
pointed to me and my friend and said
these two and they said it's a hate
crime
so she tried saying so she was
yugoslavian so she tried saying that we
beat her up because we hate europeans
my whole family is bulgarian my
grandfather does not speak english he
like he's residence peace but like he
very broken bulgarian my friend's whole
family is portuguese her no no never
said a word in her life
this is not a hate crime our whole
family is european we no one speaks
english i don't know you can't use this
so my dad was like you can't use this as
an excuse all right so my my dad went in
and her mom went in
and they fought and fought and fought
and they got us back in the school so we
were expelled for i guess suspended long
spending for a month
then we got back in because like my
parents both graduated from that high
school and their grandparents said they
needed me to go there it's this whole
[ __ ] thing but is that all expunged
off your [ __ ] or if you get in trouble
these days is that's just floating
around no i i don't think i can be a cop
or
[Laughter]
boo hoo um my fallback of being a female
police officer i don't know i i think in
canada they can really find it
but it's like we were i was excited what
happened to the girl what she just got i
hope that she's been watching me on
netflix i hope she sat down with her
mother and she get [ __ ] up with her
live stream no she was fine she wasn't
she wasn't she went in for a day she had
like a bruise nothing was wrong with her
it was it was a high school like a good
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah she got she got
her ass beat don't be shoving me yes so
ask me at any point do you ever stick up
for yourself
and it changes
or did you just outlast it and then a
couple people apologize i think yeah i
outlasted i think i just i got more
popular so people stopped making fun of
me and when did the bullying actually
stop i'd say grade 10 also after i got
like arrested people i think i thought i
was like a badass so they were like the
whole thing
and i was like i didn't care i came i
was like super like yeah i was a big
punker so i'd wear wild [ __ ] i'd wear
like two different color fishnets with
like striped socks i was like you know
a dog color's weird like
so i was kind of like in a weird like
the drama crew so nobody was like
[ __ ] with that and by that point i
think they were over it the the bullies
kind of
[ __ ] off and are you dating at the
time at all you said you lost your
virginity late but are you dating at all
in high school or anything after that
there's no punk boys in that circle or
no i like um
no i i was like in love with one of my
best friends in high school who uh
led me on for a couple years and nothing
ever happened with that i was like oh
that's nice but you would have liked it
too oh yeah or you would yeah he told me
every day that he's gonna leave his
girlfriend and never did one of those
situations uh you're if you're listening
you know who you are
they're all coming out
i'm like i'm gonna go for this um
oh god
um
so that was like my start to like you
know
uh dating hell and then i ended up
having a serious boyfriend from
19 to 24 that i met in college
okay and then that went well where's
college toronto so i ended up going to
uh i applied to be like i want to be an
actor and then that didn't happen um
because i didn't get into any of the
schools i
applied to four and they're like no
uh and we have a comedy writing
performance program like a two-year
college program so i took that that's
cool
excuse me it was the more like you know
getting high every day and i lived with
eight guys so we would just smoke weed
and play foosball and baby none of those
dated nights one of them one yeah so
that's so one of them that was the guy
yeah that was the guy
so this is a weird fact so i dated this
man steve he doesn't care what talk
about him great guy
love steve dubetz it just you know he's
the first guy i ever dated
he could have been married and i was
like i
i'm not i'm 24. i've never dated anybody
else he's the only guy i've had sex with
i can't live like this and i turned out
to be a raging [ __ ] after him but
anyways um
before that i was i was a little meek
girl um
steve became very close to my father
when i was dating him and again let me
rephrase i broke up when we were 24
years old i'm not 37 um
steve still talks to my dad and i don't
mean just like here and there
i mean
steve calls my father every father's day
every birthday every christmas
sent a screenshot so i'm in a group
thread with other the guys i used to
live with they all find it quite amusing
that steve is good friends with my
father i don't as much find it funny so
they
two days ago steve's in the screenshot
he talked to my father for 30 minutes on
the phone why
what is the bomb i don't know
i find it he has a wife
he has a wife he just loves my dad wins
and didn't work his wife was your dad i
did not yes he my dad has slept over at
him and his wife's house
yes she had wiring in the house it's
[ __ ] weird you need some boundaries
isn't it crazy
no one believes you might tell them this
i'm like it's so odd a boyfriend from 13
years ago
is like i i look i can understand every
now and then a merry christmas or
whatever if he's good to him this is
best friends it sounds like best
friendship yeah wiring someone's house
it's
sleeping over sleeping over yeah
apparently steve just moved to a new
house and he asked him to come help him
out with the the wiring in the garage
it needs to end at some point i'm like
this is and
and
steve invited my mum and dad to his
wedding and not me
is that not [ __ ] twisted
that's psychotic
it's truly unhinged summer is full of
official events like weddings
graduations and annual barbecues but
everyone knows the best summer moments
are the unofficial ones summer is
officially the warmest time of the year
unofficially it's the chillest the
weekend is officially saturday and
sunday unofficially it's friday
afternoon too y'all coors light is the
official beer of everything unofficial
celebrating those casual off-the-cuff
moments that truly make summer chill i
just had my good buddy eric out here
from childhood
they were putting my name on the comedy
store wall and he's like we're drinking
and i was like we are and he's like
we're getting coors light and i was like
we're only getting coors light and i'm
telling you there's a sizeable dent
in the amount of coors light left in
southern california coors light is cold
lager co-filtered and cold packaged it
is literally made to chill it's as crisp
and refreshing as the colorado rockies
perfect for a moment to unwind summer
chill starts with coors like to check
out what coors light has going on this
summer visit
coorslightsummer.com celebrate
responsibly coors brewing company golden
colorado did you know that an estimated
5 billion plastic hand soap and cleaning
bottles are thrown away each year most
cleaning formulas are 90 water which is
heavy to ship leading to excessive
carbon emissions those products are
often filled with nasty ingredients like
chlorine and ammonia blue land is on a
mission to eliminate single-use plastics
by reinventing home essentials that are
good for you and the planet blueland's
innovative tablet refill solution takes
up 10 times less space than a
traditional bottle and their powerful
formulas keep your home clean and
smelling amazing the idea is simple you
grab one of the beautiful forever
bottles you fill it with warm water you
drop in the tablet and you get cleaning
refills start at two dollars and you
don't even have to buy a new plastic
bottle every time you run out you can
even set up a subscription so you never
run out of the products you use the most
from cleaning sprays to hand soap to
toilet cleaner and laundry tablets all
blue lamb products are made with
ingredients you can feel good about try
their clean essentials kit which has
everything you need to get started
products come in refreshing signature
scents like iris agave fresh lemon and
eucalyptus mint and for a limited time
their hand soap is getting a summer
upgrade with three refreshing new scents
strawberry rhubarb citrus patchouli and
coconut palm right now you can get 15
off your first order when you go to
blueland.com
honeydew that's 15 percent off your
first order of any blue land products at
blueland.com honeydew blueland.com
honeydew it's summer lighten up dag
grass is great anytime they can help you
chill out before a big meeting or be a
new replacement to that evening glass of
wine they are the perfect pairing to
everything summer has to offer dag grass
is legal organic hemp that relaxes your
body and mellows your mind dag grass cbd
products are made with 100 organic hemp
that's easy to dose and the effects come
on smooth they offer a variety of
products from their token smokable
pre-rolled joints as well as hemp flour
and a variety of cbd tincture drops
enjoy the effects of cbd while keeping a
clear head all daggrass products are
federally legal for ages 18 and over and
it ships right to your door anywhere in
the u.s go to daggrass.com
honeydew to check out their products
whether you're looking for a new buzz or
a chill way to enjoy an old favorite dad
grass will leave you in a euphoric mood
right now that grass is offering my
listeners 20 off your first order when
you go to daggrass.com
honeydew go to dadgrass.com
honeydew for 20 off your first order
that's dadgrass.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
what is are your parents still together
yes they are okay so what is your
relationship like with your let's start
with your dad is this is this typical
like this sort of thing with steve or
no no no no no me my dad we get along
now
which is great but we did not get along
we were younger we butt heads uh a lot
my dad's a very angry man very short
tempered is the term i guess i'll use um
so it's like zero to i think he has
bipolar but it's never been diagnosed
because it'll go from like zero to rage
in in such a way where you're like this
doesn't make sense how you got here
there's something i googled recently
called rage um induced blackouts i'm not
sure if you heard this where when you
get so mad you just your brain kind of
clicks off and you say [ __ ] and you
don't remember it you don't even know
so during when i was in high school uh
right after high school first year
college we we fought a lot over like
nothing small things would annoy him and
i got like i got snippy back where's my
dinner i'm like i'm not your [ __ ]
maid make your own [ __ ] dinner and
then we would like rage out at each
other
uh and then one day when i was 18 we got
in a big fight and i said something i
think it was over the [ __ ] kitchen
scissors and he was like what the [ __ ]
are they like [ __ ] use your eyes
and then i feel this chair come flying
at my head uh and he threw like this big
stool up my head and i was like hit you
hit me head and i'm like i'm like [ __ ]
you and then i we got in a fight like i
got a physical fight with my dad and i
was like you got in a physical fight
with your dad i was on the couch i
remember i was like i was so scared i'm
like he's gonna [ __ ] i'm like i can't
take my dad no [ __ ] way i get that me
on my [ __ ] dog caller i'm like i
can't take [ __ ] i'm like oh yeah put me
on my feet i'm like yeah put me in a
mosh pit maybe i'm like i am [ __ ] so i
remember i kicked him in the balls
really hard steph you kicked your father
in the ball so hard and i ran to my
friend's house with no shoes or socks on
him
[Laughter]
i was like i have to get the [ __ ] out of
here and i stayed at my friend's house
like three days and then i moved
i'm so scared
i'm going to be [ __ ] murdered like
are you kidding me right now so i
literally ran and i stayed there and
then i moved out you did i moved out i
had 250 in my bank account and i moved
into the house of the guys boom just
like that oh yeah and what time at what
point do you finally talk to your dad uh
after i was like i'm moving out and i'm
scared now but the thing with his like
rage where he would get so mad be mad
for a couple days and then be like
normal again and then not remember what
happened so like in the pandemic we had
a similar situation where we got in a
[ __ ]
psychotic fight because like it's also i
was home for a bit it was too long
physically together there together a lot
and like something happened i made a
comment about something that pissed him
off and he snapped and i got so mad i
remember stirring my coffee go fight me
and at this point i'm like i'm a bit
stronger now i'm like he's got some bad
feet i'm like i think i could i i could
be
62 63 i'm like i could throw a couple
punches i'm not a senior citizen yet
that's not a hate crime yeah yeah
i could get a couple in there before i
get beat the hell up i'm like i gotta
run them um so i put my coffee down my
mom was just in there like what the
[ __ ] going on and i was like i'm gonna
fight me i'm like go right now i'm like
i can't deal with this [ __ ] i'm like
[ __ ] hit me right [ __ ] now and we
don't he's there for a second i'm like i
think he's going to thank god he didn't
because i'm like that it would have been
bad
i'll be on this massive fight and then i
didn't talk to him for five months whoa
yeah it was the longest i ever gone and
i emailed him he kept emailing me like
what's going on why aren't we talking
and i'm like and i emailed him with
exactly what he said to me i'm like you
said this this and very hurtful things
like i'm not funny no guys like me like
things that i already knew about myself
that i like you know i'm saying like
it's like he found everything in my head
that i always thought about myself and
just set it back to me and then
afterwards i was like you said he's like
i never said any of that i'm like
oh are you are you joking and i had a
very serious conversation i'm like are
you do you actually remember saying this
is like i swear i didn't do everything
any of that i'm like
then something's up and then i googled
it and there's the the rage induced like
[ __ ] blackouts which i'm like it
sounds crazy but i'm like if you don't
remember because it was wild [ __ ] he was
saying like really insane [ __ ] i'm like
nobody likes me i'm like okay chill i
have a lot of sex um
they like me when i'm in bed
you better not hear this we have to
block him i have to block him on
instagram when this comes out
so how did you end up patching things up
um
he agreed to get some help for his anger
issues
okay and i think he did like some online
classes and stuff and now it's like it's
way better now like i'm like i talked to
my dad every day okay like we're super
chill and like so it made a difference
yeah these clips can't make it to
instagram but yeah yeah
good for you know an old dog learning
new trick
i mean he must love you enough to say
all right and that's the thing i know he
does love me and he's so [ __ ]
supportive like he's like he wears my
merch all the time like my dad is a step
solo shirt that he took to south africa
he did to scotland he was he wears the
cottage he's like selling them people to
college like i know he's like
probably my sister the most supportive
of my comedy but it's like he just has
like
an anger problem and that's that's
that's that how's your mom dealt with it
all these years don't you ever ask her
she yeah no she eggs him on she
she likes to push poke the bear whatever
it's called she likes to push him and
then but you made the difference
yeah i think so yeah because i'm like
i'm like i can't deal with it anymore
um but yeah she my mom is very
what's the word
[Laughter]
she likes to
brag
your mom does
not about me but about like her eleven
time champion that and like
yeah literally dancing is her life
dancing is her life so dancing is like
my mom's everything is dancing so like
me my sister like you know my mom would
be teaching every weekend or whatever
like on trips like judging and stuff and
like so my dad pretty much raised me my
sister my mom was like never around okay
so yeah it's it's a very
interesting relationship we had with her
recently and she like if i say something
like i know she's trying to be nice but
i'll be like oh i had a meeting with nbc
and then all of a sudden two of her
friends are like facing me and go nbc
signed you i'm like what are you talking
about that is so annoying it's psychotic
i said i have a meeting with like will
ferrell's coming this week and she's
like so when's the movie with will
ferrell i'm like what the hell are you
on about right now i never said that
like you take one thing you you don't
listen to me every time i call her she's
like on the computer i'm like you know
listen to music anyways i was out like
i'm watching you not listen to what i'm
saying right now like you're just in
your own world it's all about dancing
it's just very
i mean no one's getting along great with
their parents and if they are
you're not a comedian
[Laughter]
if you like i remember i met my my
sketch partner actually allison hogg
very funny comedian in canada i've never
met her parents and i they were kissing
the whole time at dinner and holding
hands i remember sitting there being
like what the [ __ ]
after dinner i'm like
i'm sorry do your parents always do that
and she's like yeah doing yours i'm like
i haven't seen my parents kiss on the
lips my whole life i'm like i don't
think they know they haven't remember
seeing my parents hug once yeah yeah hug
once and that's and that is like that's
probably cemented in your head and i'm
like
huh oh yeah so i was like that was wild
to
to see that oh my god you don't realize
we talk about this all the time you
don't realize how
uh
unknown what is it abnormal your life is
until you go start going to other
people's homes oh yeah you know i was
joking about all the time like you guys
get hugs
oh i see people like say cereals and the
foods and their habits and once i love
yous i'm like yeah hugs and one friend
could cuss in front of his parents our
friend jason danlowski shout out to
jason alaska he could cuss everything
but [ __ ] he was allowed to say the first
time we're over there he's like that's
[ __ ] that we were all like
and they oh do anything and we're like
oh okay he's not gonna do anything like
they're gonna beat you after you leave
and he's like no i'm allowed to cuss
like not eyes like wow and this was
middle school
sixth grade wow that's young yep
[ __ ]
i remember i cursed a lot as a kid
because they would curse and then they
got mad when i did i'm like what the
[ __ ] you talking about yeah my mom
didn't say she loved me she started
saying it like um the last four years
okay what what happened i don't know i
think
did she drop it on you yeah because i
remember as a kid she'd be like okay
good night and we'd be like
good night
bye bye mom see ya good night hey shut
up the door on the way out like what the
[ __ ] oh i'll tuck i'll get the blanket
don't worry about that i'll get the
sex i'll get the blanket don't worry
i'm just reading myself a story just so
sad and good night moon i'm just crying
myself asleep um
my dad said it but my mom never
i think she was this angry guy would
give you the i love you huh the angry
guy was still like as angry he was he
was still very emotional
yeah he used to know how to process his
anger but he was very loving like i will
say minus the throwing of the chairs
but he wasn't throwing he was throwing
kisses
no he was he was he was loving but he
was just angry my mom was just uh kind
of closed off and not loving so now i
think she's trying a bit more but when
she says it now she's like she's still
saying i'll go what she's like i love
you i'm like oh uh i love you bye
because i'm like i'm not used to and i
haven't i've been no relationships that
are have been anything in the last like
i haven't been in loves
and you look at me
i'm gonna say
it's gonna sound sad maybe like 10 years
is this because of stephen
no it wasn't steve
but are you worried that the boyfriend
is going to be buddies with your dad
again
yeah that's that's why i've been alone
[Laughter]
when's the last time you're in love you
said 10 years i'm going to say 10 years
but the last guy i was in love with uh
emotionally [ __ ] me in such a way that
i
don't know it'll take a long time for me
to be in love with somebody again
he was very like one day he loved me one
day he told me to get the [ __ ] out of
his house the next day he was like
making up me in front of me the next day
we were just friends the next day it was
like very like
very back and forth
i actually
we also have matching tattoos that i
need to get covered up because it's
haunting to look at um how long were you
together well technically to him we
never were so what yeah what do you mean
it was an on and off thing that we had
for several years and then years
we started [ __ ] when i was 27 and
then uh we [ __ ] until i moved to
l.a and that was uh 30. it's a long time
30 31 yeah that's a three four year
release
it was like very like it was very back
and forth i guess
so he was not in love or he was at one
point he said he often said he was in
love with me and then he wouldn't say it
again and then he would it was very
[ __ ] up and i i randomly saw him uh
about in november at a
festival in canada and um the comedian
and i'm not gonna say his name because
last time i i talked about him on a
podcast he dropped enough [ __ ] money
and also last time i mentioned uh this
scenario on a podcast he made them take
it off because it was friends of mine
i'm like i'm not taking this off sorry
you [ __ ] me he's also he's a pattern
what he does with other women also when
you [ __ ] somebody emotionally this badly
like it's a it's a lot it's it's when
you get a matching tattoo with someone
and then you say you went over with them
it's confusing you know you get confused
yeah
yeah i ended up approaching him and like
giving him the run down and like
i like cathartically came out and told
him everything i'm like you did this and
this is then i started crying and i was
like it felt not like a sad cry but like
oh my [ __ ] god this feels good to
come out cry so i think i'm like
i'm obviously over that but he take it
apparently shocked
i don't know
okay you're
whatever it's uh i don't think about him
um but yeah it was um that was a lot so
that that was the last like kind of like
that's the last time i probably was in
love and then since then i've had like
little
i've had a couple like three monthers
here and there and like
i had like a i had a copy relationship
with a guy who
there's a pattern with me where men just
ghost me it's just like a [ __ ]
doesn't matter how long like three four
months five months nothing they just
talking to you every day
and then
yeah i had a guy in toronto we were
together for like the whole path of him
in four months and then i came back to
la and i was like we were still kind of
talking he's like i can't do this and
then never talk to me again i'm like
okay not i met someone
no can't do this never talk to me again
i had another guy um from vancouver that
reached out to me as a fan we had this
weird three-month thing we were like
facetiming every day and he was like i
just wanna make you my girlfriend i just
wanna come visit you and then like i
told him i was gonna come visit him and
then uh he goes to me and then funny
enough
funny enough i got an email
i got an email right after the netflix
came out oh did you that isn't that
funny timing mm-hmm
yeah that email saying it was an attempt
at an apology at no point did he say he
was sorry he said i should never have
tried to get in an intimate relationship
with you i'm disgusted with my behavior
i should never have ghosted you
no i'm sorry no i can't believe what i
put you through nothing i wanted to like
oh yeah i i mean i've had women call me
out on [ __ ] before and i just have to
you got to eat it and i just i write
back you're right i'm sorry i won't
contact you again it's that easy like
it's also i guarantee you've never
ghosted like that i've never ghosted
like that on that see that's the problem
this is the issue the issue is i had the
uncomfortable conversation
every time and nine out of ten if it was
possible was it person to person it was
not [ __ ] that's even ballsy that's
great you know if you're gonna here's
the thing i don't know i don't care if
you're gonna let me
do all the [ __ ] that we're gonna do
sexually the least i can do is talk to a
person and say this isn't working out
yes and that's thank you
men
men are you listening to this it's they
let you see their butthole the least you
could do
is talk to them face to face when you're
saying goodbye or butthole to face if
you if you if you're still into it you
know whatever if you're an ass guy it's
like also you can like i don't i'm not
talking about the like the one or two
week like tinder thing you hook up you
don't who cares about that i've never
even done that so i'm talking about what
we're talking about i'm talking about
like an actual you're gonna [ __ ] talk
this woman every day you're gonna send
[ __ ] all this i had another guy that
i met in january that we had like a very
we got close i met him when i was in
grand rapids and it was like i was like
super into him and it was like talking
every day in like four months talking
talking talking gonna go visit him after
the billboard taping and then i do not
hear from him for a month and i'm like
[ __ ] this so i [ __ ] snapped and wrote
this big thing and being like [ __ ] you
you don't [ __ ] deserve this you don't
deserve to [ __ ] call me every day say
you like me all this [ __ ] it [ __ ]
with me i can't be i cannot work it does
any time i try to go now i'm like you
can't ghost me i i will go off the rails
like
i also decided guys which is like so
i i don't know how they came through
their thick [ __ ] heads
i get
told no i get told
i'm every day a no i don't want this i
don't want you you didn't book the part
every [ __ ] day in my life i get it
you saying you don't see me anymore is
not going to affect me in the way you
think it is i'm going to be oh no this
guy who smokes a thousand cigarettes a
day and [ __ ] his dick doesn't get
hurt doesn't seem anymore i don't give a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you like i don't give a [ __ ] i
get more upset when they're like no
you didn't get a call back for the job
to move you're like yeah that i'm gonna
be upset about this i'm not gonna like
it's so insane to not be bought like
just just [ __ ] it's
it's very frustrating so that's why i'm
scared now to even get in a relationship
even like talking about it i'm talking
to somebody now and i can't even tell if
he likes me it's very strange i'm like
it's a weird time it is you know the the
um
readiness and availability of penis and
vagina is too much it's too much you
know the apps are too much back in the
old days back in the old days um
you probably you met someone local you
maybe met him at a bar or at the store
or a friend of a friend you know what i
mean and and you held on to a
relationship because there weren't ten
thousand other opportunities on this
[ __ ] app that i could just touch with
my finger you know what i mean so i feel
like a lot of people devalue
relationships these days because it's so
easy to hop on to the next dick or put
your back in the next hole you know what
i mean yeah that's right um
so i think that uh plays a part in it
and
also i don't know i i don't know if it's
a generational thing i don't know but i
hear from a lot of my girlfriends that
guys do this won't talk to him for three
or four days and it's like this is your
boyfriend yeah haven't talked to you for
a week
won't come over tonight constantly
canceling plans like
i just is that that's not a boyfriend no
no i don't trust anybody anymore so this
guy i'm talking to now i'm like i don't
i think we're just talking
he brought actually he brought a friend
to my show tonight the comedy store and
i was like oh what did you tell your
friend like who who are you going to see
he said a girl i'm talking to i'm like
okay so talking to me means he's still
in the apps he's still probably talking
to other women and i'm like all right i
guess i'm also talking to other men and
like doing whatever i'm like i'm not in
a relationship if you're i'm also
haven't heard from one day so it's like
like what is this i i'm also just like
i'm over unless a man is like obsessed
with me like i don't be obsessed with
like i mean i know you know i mean like
calling me every day checking in like
unless someone's doing that that's what
i want right now that's what i want a
guy that really i'm like i'm not gonna
force i have some friends who are like
you know
men and women who are like with people
they don't really like was like oh you
know they're nice enough i'm like i
don't want that i want someone that i'm
like i want to [ __ ] you all the time i
want you to like be around me while you
meet my family i want to tell you while
you're at work and say hi check in has
your day going get home i'm always like
that when you get home call me when
you're inside and say like that's that's
it
that's it it's a nice it's a nice normal
thing to care about some well it's also
it's not hard to care about somebody you
care about yeah and then i'm like so and
then when you don't feel that you're
like oh you just don't care about me
that's exactly you know what i mean
that's it it's not hard to care about no
that's about or love someone you love
yeah so when you don't feel it you're
feeling exactly you're feeling is
accurate yeah so this person doesn't
give a [ __ ] that's what's so right now
i'm like this doesn't get [ __ ] like
so i have to have a chat with me i have
to be like in college like hey i don't
this is not working for me this is not
what i want like do you have to do that
though i guess not yeah i guess i don't
need to move on yeah because i'm like
this is it's like it's already what you
don't want you don't owe that guy that's
not telling you and you know being
behaving the way you don't want them
he knows yeah you're right i mean it's
an interesting description these days
it's a girl i'm talking to huh
is that i'm like but i'm like i also
haven't been in a relationship in so
long i'm like is that what people say i
don't know anymore i'm so confused i'm
also just like i don't know if it's
exhausting we don't need to know all
that it's you gotta just connect with
that person that the same [ __ ] jives for
you yeah you know what i mean like
you're like that i'm like that yeah you
also don't want someone that wants to
call you all the time check in on you
but that other person's like oh you're
suffocating you know yeah no no yeah
yeah i don't yeah exactly i don't want
that i'm like oh i get it i don't need
you up my ass around the corner i like a
nice like a daily check-in like a good
morning i like a good night if you have
and i like to know i'm a planner i like
a plan give me a plan let me know what's
going on i like to i like to know i like
it there's not like the days i'm maybe
gonna come to the bar maybe meet you
later i'm like it's maybes i don't do
maybes you're coming or not otherwise
i'm gonna [ __ ] somebody else like mama's
horny oh i'm not waiting around maybe
i'll maybe find somebody else maybe
nothing i'm annoyed
it's too much is the dating scene's
exhausting out here i'm just like it's
been like oh you want to talk about
lowe's i'm going to get real dark here
when i first moved out here i um
[Music]
i was almost raped i was very [ __ ] up
in l.a in l.a in l.a i was um this guy
who kind of was a comedian lived in this
weird
halfway house thing i'm not really sure
what it was and i went to meet him and
then we were going just to go to a bar
and i were getting there and it's like
it was all dark he's like you can't talk
in here it's quiet it's like it's 10
o'clock what's going on somebody's
sitting there and this like guy comes
out of this room and he's like whoa
who's this and i'm like oh hi is it who
are you and i'm like and i'm gonna
remember being oh i don't like
this guy this is a bad guy i want to be
around him we don't want to bars can i
come and i'm like i hate this man so we
go to the bar my friend's like oh i have
to go grab weed he runs before they're
like selling wheat everywhere out here
he runs off i'm stuck with this [ __ ]
weirdo guy
so i'm like okay let's let's walk back
and find him so we start walking back
outside and remember to walk in front i
want to watch you walk i want to watch
your legs and i'm like hey man you're
like really creeping me out i'm like can
you please stop like i i don't feel
uncomfortable right now please stop and
i'm like kind of drunk because i've had
a couple drinks i can meet him whatever
we end up going i have to go to the
bathroom now somebody can i go back to
your house go pee i go to the bathroom
he tries to come in the bathroom and i
go oh no he's like let me come in i'm
like i'm going the bathroom so we're
closing the door i'm like trying to find
my phone i'm like texting my friend like
where the [ __ ] are you my your friend's
freaking me out what the [ __ ] is going
on so i'm taxiing texans in the bathroom
come out he takes me outside puts me
against the wall and it's like really
kissing me and i'm like okay i'm like
sorry i'm like i think i gave you the
wrong idea i don't want this he's like
you know you want it and i'm like and
he's like really strong like he's kind
of scrawny i'm like god damn this guy's
strong i'm like this is not good
something's gonna happen i can tell
something bad
parched
my rape story's making me thirsty
[Laughter]
you gotta laugh at it sometimes
so
i remember we were in silver lake and it
was like this weird area so come come
see this hill i'm like i don't want to
see this celestia come with me right now
and like grab my hand i'm like if i
don't do what this guy says i'm like
he's freaking me out kill you i'm like
i'm worried so he gets the top of the
cell and he's like dragging my hand not
dragging like he's holding my hand
really tightly and i'm like i keep
trying to grab my phone i'm like where
the [ __ ] is this guy what the [ __ ] is
going on right now gets the top of the
hill and there's this like um
uh
box opened up like like i'm like i
literally out loud i went this is where
you bring all your victims and he did
not laugh and i was like oh my god this
is where he brings his victims and then
he like shoved me to the ground i'm like
um oh my god and he like
shoved i was wearing shorts and he
shoved his finger inside me like so
badly i like i might stop and i yelled
stop and i like pulled his hand out and
like it it was so bad it bled when i got
home the next day that night
like i was like saying no so i kept like
i remember in the moment i'm like i'm
always been that girl where i'm like if
i get raped i'm gonna kick his ass this
guy can't do [ __ ] you go [ __ ] numb
i lied there i'm like i literally in my
head when i'm getting raped deal with it
in the morning and i kept like it was
[ __ ] and i'm like always i've always
hello i got a rest of her salt like i'm
i'm like if a guy [ __ ] bugs me i'll
shove him back like i'm not your dad
yeah
i'm a tough [ __ ] girl like i'm not i
don't take [ __ ] and this was like oh i'm
about to be raped and this is this is my
life and i just ask you
does does this
like wash of disbelief just paralyze you
like i can't believe this is no no this
is like it's this is not it's not
happening
it's like you can't even like process it
process it and you your body's [ __ ]
frozen like i've already shoved fingers
inside and i already i got those out and
i just in my head now what he's shoving
you to the ground so i'm on the ground
he's on top of me and he's holding me
down no i can't scream i'm not i can't
you can't scream like you always think
it's that nightmare dream where you
[ __ ] can't yell and i'm like i'm like
in my head i'm like there's got to be
something you can do to just get him to
stop so i just kept kissing him and i
kept distracting him and it kept i guess
he hadn't been kissed in a long time so
he was like getting really into the
kissing so i finally was like i got up i
like rolled over and i was like it was
[ __ ] so i get up and i'm like so we're
kissing he's kissing him so i'm like
okay i'm like i have to go he said go
out like and then i ran i [ __ ] booked
it i booked it i don't know where the
[ __ ] i wasn't silver like i [ __ ] bo i
turned around he wasn't there i'm like
oh my god i get on the court i stay at
my friend's house at the time i said a
massive leak in my apartment in la so i
was like i stay my friend's house i get
against the apartment i was headlining
this big club in canada for the first
time ever so i remember getting to her
apartment scrubbing my body like just in
the shower just scrubbing everything
[ __ ] off my body like his his smell
was on me uh and i remember i told his
friend i'm like hey your friend tried to
rape me what the [ __ ] and he's like no
no no he is ptsd from the war you can't
i'm like i can't what report him he's
like no he's really like he he he's
something's happened him in the war he's
not well i'm like i don't give a [ __ ]
what happened in the war your friend
tried to [ __ ] rape me like what the
hell
that guy did nothing and then weirdly
enough that that guy came to a show of
mine like the last few months no then
i'm reaper the friend and he like took
me he came to the show and i was like i
got paralyzed i was like and i got this
whole like feeling all over the things
i'd be like oh my god then i just the
playing again in my head i'm like oh my
[ __ ] god and then
i i took him outside of the show he's
like hey sorry to show up like that i'm
like yeah man what are you doing here
like you can't be here and he like i'm
so sorry i should have believed you i
was going through my own [ __ ] i wasn't
listening to the time but like i've
always regretted not like you know
helping you out i'm like yeah i'm like
and now i'm like i probably still could
report this guy i'm like i don't even i
asked him i i would still report him if
we can get his name and like
some idea of his whereabouts like he's
probably doing that to other [ __ ]
women like he's a bad man like this is
like
yeah it's a nightmare
damn stuff but it's like really like i i
just like i i sympathize with women
where it's like
oh oh they get raped there's lie don't
take it you you can't plan what you do
you think you can you think you can like
grab and whatever the [ __ ] but it's like
you are completely still and there's
nothing you can do and i'm like
i've never like i've been in so many
fights i've been like me and my friend
got kicked out of this nightclub one
time we both start throwing punches uh
my birthday once this girl saw my phone
i fought three chicks and a guy like i
am a [ __ ] tough [ __ ] but it's like
some situations your body just doesn't
[ __ ] move well tough doesn't always
just mean physically either you were
mentally tough in that situation to give
yourself up enough to kiss the guy to
save yourself so let me ask you straight
up if you didn't do that there's no way
you were getting he was strong as [ __ ]
he was strong and he was you know it was
gonna happen he was strong as [ __ ] and
he was like so small i can't believe he
like let his guard down
night mare on elm street it was awful
and i was like hmm that's
that's dating in l.a
like it's bad and i thought of all the
other women like that had been that
situation like how many women before him
have been in situations with this guy
like he looked like christian bale with
a long beard if anyone
anyone knows this guy [ __ ] dm me and
we'll talk about it but like yeah it was
like it's [ __ ]
it's really it's really scary
and it's also like now like all these
like if you've watched these like crazy
like
this guy i don't know this is this one
stupid thing recently was like a guy
tinder takes a girl into the hotel room
and then comes out the next day with a
couple suitcases i'm like what is going
on like i don't trust anybody anymore
everyone is not to be trusted
which is scary
i want to trust people but it's i don't
yeah i mean
just being a dad of a daughter who's
gonna date eventually probably on apps
oh yeah freaks me the [ __ ] out how old
is she she's seven now but who knows
what it's gonna be like in 11 more years
and you're gonna be on these apps with
all these different guys and here and
there probably trying to meet mr right
and i'm just going to be [ __ ]
hopefully she's getting [ __ ] in my
silver
no i'm serious i'm dead serious
if i have kids i'll tell you right now
[ __ ] gay all the way i want gay kids
i want to be gay
i i've tried i would love nothing more i
mean you've tried i've tried i've been
with several women i keep i go in the
app sometimes for women i'm like i keep
trying to be with a woman because i'm
like i can't i go through these phases
where i'm like do i hey man i'm like i
get so mad like after [ __ ] like that and
like get a ghost
here's what i always say and i'm like
this is so offensive but i'm like i want
to get a shirt made that says i've eaten
out more [ __ ] than all the buy women in
los angeles every [ __ ] comic is
buying now i'm like [ __ ] prove it prove
it eat me out prove it come right here
like i'm [ __ ] i don't identify i mean
i guess i am bi but i don't like
saying by on stage or like saying bye to
like can't work clearly i'm like up
there jerking off men everything i have
but um
you know i i think
i i do i think it for me with women it's
certain women
it's not like all guys i see them like a
pervert on my checking every guy out but
like some women i'm like jesus christ
what gets you for the ladies i don't
know it's it's a mix it's just a thing
yeah it's like a really you know when
you see it yeah the first time ever
happened to me i was in amsterdam when i
was 24. uh because i really wanted to
move there
there was a i don't know why i have a
giant windmill tattoo in my back so i
was like i wouldn't be really oh yeah
i'm like obsessed with that how big of a
windmill that's kind of like this way
that's pretty big
it's way too big it's it's absurd to be
honest it's way too much um if i was
further along on my diet program i'll
show you right now she's greater than
that
no it's a lot um but i met this girl
around the bridge when i was with steve
actually the time and my two other
friends we were like walking across this
bridge and this beautiful blonde woman
stopped and she was like saying
something she goes your voice and i'm
like she goes oh i love the sound of
your voice i was like
i remember like that's the first time
ever i was like
and i was like oh i like girls like that
was like the first ever little like
spark i had but it's only specific women
what was it like for you the first time
you went out the woman um it was right
after i was steve actually yeah because
he was like you know one guy i was like
whatever so right after broke up steve
uh most of my friends are gay so we were
out in toronto dancing and they look
over like uh what are steph's handling
the breakup and there's me and this girl
like just [ __ ]
making it like oh i guess she's doing
okay yeah yeah she seems to be doing
fine um and then we dated for like three
months but i was not what's the
difference
is it um do you feel safer yes and it's
definitely safer and it was just
definitely more
sensual
yeah yeah okay if you ever kissed a
woman ladies you should it's very like
just so some guys too many guys can't
kiss i wish i could do like a class
um it's just disgusting
what are you doing
it's repulsive and some tongues are so
hot when they go in there i'm like i
don't know what you're doing before this
but there's a lot of like
it's gross there's a lot of bat
before older older men too
because i i dip around i don't have an
age group what's the
oldest the gap the longest i don't know
crystallia i i do i do
i'm starting 27 i went on the days time
i'm too young and i'm thirty seven
twenty twenty seven what about the other
way i'm saying either way i've gone up
to sixty-five no
have you yeah i did i didn't date with
you on a few dates yeah i didn't think
your date is six no i didn't work
didn't how was work well didn't work it
didn't work at all i needed a pill and
he was denying him i can just take the
pill i don't care if you take the pill
i'd like you to take the pill how old
were you when you dated a 65 year old
that was a couple years ago
now all right so if outside of that
didn't work did you have a good time on
those dates did you yeah no i like you
really were you able to talk to them
connect with yeah yeah yeah okay yeah i
can yeah i think i i don't have an any
age restriction except that i check ids
and that i don't hang around in high
schools um i i'm with you on that you
know what i don't i don't care anymore
either i'm not i mean hot that's way too
young no uh but
if you're just [ __ ] just be nice it's i
just want you nice that's it man i don't
care if you're 27 i don't care if you're
67. just be [ __ ] nice i want a nice
man whose penis works that's all i want
fair enough that's all i'm asking for
you're nice here's my top three you're
tall you're nice and you're funny how
what's talking and you find me funny
that's the key i need you to because if
you don't find me funny it's that's like
that's a turn-off for me one guy if you
don't find your partner funny forget
about comics no in general your
partner's got to make you laugh funny in
person and yes and funny on stage i'm
like i want a guy to come see me and
like die laughing and i know him i know
him a lot up there
i'm well aware of what i'm putting out
it's
not a turn-on for most men um
tall for me i like i like over six feet
mostly because i'm a larger gal and i
don't like feeling every guy i end up
being with i'm the same size or small
larger i'm like i don't know how are you
five seven okay but i'm white so i'm
like i don't want to be i hate get your
dad's back
i don't want to be [ __ ] i'm always a
big fan like it was a joke at first i'm
like i'm always the biggest spoon and
i'm sick and tired of it i don't want to
be the one latching onto you it's like
no you latch onto me i want like a big
strong
man it's hard to find out here
apparently los angeles doesn't exist any
other city yeah sure great
go to any other city in the goddamn
country and find a big strong man but
here no i know everyone's paulie and
everyone's flopping around everywhere
it's too much
it's wild out here it's too much it's a
free-for-all
every time i match the guy they're like
uh i have six wives i can't do this
everyone's got it's ice i'm also
paranoid of stds i don't want to have
like
maybe go in the clinic everything get
tested who you slopping with who are
they slopping with it's too much of a
slop 49 years and no std never got one
no thank god
never did but i'm knocking on one i'm
not i mean they're out there
out there yeah yeah yeah steph this has
seriously been a great episode and i
know a lot of this was not easy to talk
about thank you for coming on thank you
um before we wrap up i'm gonna ask you
after everything we've talked about now
uh this is your first time here so
advice you would give to 16 year old
steph
the biggest thing i think i'd say and i
think a lot of women can agree with me i
wish i could go back and tell myself
that i wasn't fat
i
that would have made a difference i
think it would have i was so hard on my
body when i was young growing up and i
was fit as hell i was a dancer but i
compared myself to my other friends who
were very skinny like generally and i
made myself sick i went on crazy diets i
used to i tried to be bulimic in high
school i was like really [ __ ] over my
appearance and i just wish i could go
back and i'm like god damn it [ __ ]
who cares you're growing you're you're
changing daily like
[ __ ] stop
get get get a get a grip really good for
you no i don't think anyone's ever said
that yeah
um thank you again and please promote
everything one more time listen to steph
infection listen to slobs add me on
instagram staff tolev if you're in
toronto come see me open for bilber the
23rd 24th of august 25th comedy bar in
toronto and then i have other dates on
my website
all right thank you very much thank you
um as always ryan sickler.com ryan
sickler on all social media we will talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you